[Música]
llevando la vida me decidiendo es una
buena vía
he estado aquí en esta gran institución
el lugar mencionado vivía hace menos de
dos años salir de este auditorio con un
sueño un sueño ese continente y hoy les
quiero platicar como esa idea se
convirtió en una realidad y cómo tenemos
el poder de creadores las ideas y nuevos
nuestros sueños en realidades no importa
si es arquitecto el doctor diseñador
todos tenemos el poder
nosotros identificamos tres problemas
primero que nada la falta de visibilidad
a las causas de méxico y vamos a ver
también cómo consumimos productos sin
valor o impacto la 25 elección entre las
marcas las causas
es por eso que nosotros somos un
movimiento social dedicado que creo que
nada a crear conciencia como a través
del amor genera temas innovadores
responsable para las marcas aliadas y
más que nada es último de cultura donde
ayudar es fácil es cool y es contagioso
nosotros nos damos cuenta las
estadísticas son 55 las personas
es como una de estas dos pulseras
y es por eso que las empresas tienen la
necesidad de responsabilidad social y
hay más de doscientas fundaciones del
mundo
nosotros tenemos el poder de ser el
enlace entre una y otra como conectar
una manera creativa innovadora como lo
hacemos primero que nada creamos sus
ediciones especiales para diferentes
causas adaptamos servicios
y productos para visibilidad y apoyo
a través de eventos 1 5050 que busca
inspirar las declaraciones a crear
conciertos únicos que sean rentables
pero el género ayuda es por eso que esta
responsabilidad unirnos y buscar una
sociedad más sana más extremas y todos
somos seres todos tenemos el potencial y
es por eso que cada vez más personas más
marcas y más celebridades se están
contienda menos
nosotros tenemos el poder de ser la
función de este mundo y nosotros somos
seres como les traficaban sangre este
auditorio para emprender un viaje ella
quedó decidido una mentalidad pero
regresaba otra un viaje de cualquier
joven podría pedir seis meses con tus
amigos sin tiempo
clientes pero tuve un problema estando
en ese auge me desespere
necesito ven desarrollo porque no estoy
haciendo nada
y regrese a méxico regrese a méxico
porque mi hijo davi él
tu abuelita falleció y que merece entre
noviembre y diciembre y tenía ocho meses
y mi papá dos despachos de abogados
donde no sólo estaba trabajando
estaba mejor sacaba copias el chofer era
todo
fue cuando hablé con mis hermanos y les
dije necesito su apoyo
tengo una mina hay animales son deseaban
aceleradoras ahí hay convocatorias busca
dar puedes presentar tu idea y puede ser
que tengas éxito entonces planteamos un
mundo de las ideas
y fuimos un acelerador otra senadora
donde presenté en diciembre y llega
alrededor de 70 proyectos de esos 70
sólo acepta mente me acuerdo que yo
llegué con mis hermanos con ustedes
estaba con nosotros
no sé bien lo que había pasado con esa
marca de hielo se hubiera posicionado a
la número uno en publicidad
qué pasaría si nosotros seamos
diferentes retos con marcas para que
apoyen a diferentes causas mina no te
entendemos pero felicidad
la creciente
en ese momento yo veía mi sueño hecho
realidad solo de los problemas como
patrón donde esté el programador del
diseñador no había nada de eso
entonces ya había cometido el problema
más fuerte este como un millón que no
van a roma no está como que se adapta al
tráfico debe determinar la roma de 96
dejarlos cafesg lado y la meta de vaca
no no hay manera
pero en ese momento yo de esta manera
[ __ ] no se acabe aquí
en ese poder
y tu sueño hecho realidad
[Música]
al menos una hora sin agua fabián
entonces
se descolgó
si lo haces
pero no
estaba haciendo
[Música]
en ese momento
entonces se comía muy bien eso pero
tenía felicita por
personas
sólo 15 compañeros como puede ser que 15
personas y 400
después otra vez
las hojas está pasando una estrategia
cada que salía una persona
es como marcos y se empieza a comer
lo que empieza a pasar cuatrocientas
personas
la gente empieza a llegar y la gente
empieza lugar y la gente empieza a dar y
empiezan a ver que cuando hay acción los
sounders
amigos y se acabó pero de pronto
[Aplausos]
en persona
yo sé que necesito y el bolsón
hágalo con fernando empiezo a ver su
historia y se fundación santiago con
tapones
la fundación lleve su encuentro a un
niño de botellas
ahora
cada botella y en dos pesos en 26
senadores se hizo el rector y el chavo
no sólo con 50 botellas 800 buenas
botellas con nosotros hermanos
pero han sido eso
pero qué pasa teniendo el primero me
encuentro con la oportunidad de empezar
fue de los mejores momentos porque
y eso 4 abajo
yo vendría de nada solo me dice
todas esas oportunidades
a conocer
el concepto
no necesitas
es algo que todos usaron que todos
tenemos
alfonso tú haces formas me encantan las
maneras de tu ciudad es aprendes
entonces
fundación
y el problema
porque la unión normalmente
juntos
es momento de la lista de los 50
fundaciones
por favor no te voy a soñar en 20 20 20
minutos dados en 20 días 17 fundaciones
y discriminaciones
más unidos
también es un momento único digamos el
14 de junio donde lanzamos el proyecto
en ese momento nosotros
en el proyecto
pero si ustedes quieren
la tierra
es el único valor
hoy
todos tenemos el poder de dar es el
momento de generar un cambio de la
sociedad de equipos que no convivimos
tenemos la mejor época
no decidimos de dónde venimos pero
seamos correctas la luz está en nuestras
manos porque juntos estamos muy cerca
estamos lejos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]